[Music]
[Applause]
basketball believe it or not wasn't jen
you okay
so 15 people can be on a basketball team
only 13 are able to dress for the actual
participating in the game what happens
to the other two they basically sit on
the bench not dressed in uniforms why's
they even show up it's for injuries
because they could get injured then you
can actually they gotta go get dressed
why not let them at least dress they
can't dress during that game so they're
dressed well then what do they do
they cheerlead they support their team
[Laughter]
they they get up and make sure that the
star players have a warm seat i don't
know
did they go get the water oh no no the
trainers for that it's called they don't
dress why show up go home start your
team all right continue on all right so
there's five players on the court at one
time uh-huh the general positions in
basketball do you have your guards their
positions their positions in basketball
what then you have your forwards which
is more of the position that i played
when i played basketball
and then you have your center
your center is like your big tall big
guy like think of shaquille o'neal i'm
thinking about him all the time man you
don't even need to tell me to think
about shaquille o'neal he's in the back
of my mind but you know who shaq is
yes i know why are you looking at me
like that i know so so shaq is a big guy
he's like seven foot tall he's got
enormous feet like that's your
stereotypical sex you gotta have big
feet that's like a regular usually when
you're tall you have big feet i don't
know man i don't know if that's
correlated they don't say that about big
feet they say other things about big t
oh yeah
listen what size is your shoe mine's uh
like a 10 and a half yeah i'm a 12. i'm
taller what are you trying to say man
what are you trying to say i'm saying
[Laughter]
i got bigger socks
my feet are longer hey socks are in
categories one size fits most you get
12. we wear the same socks we are the
same it's 9 to 12 and then there's a 13
plus well you're not 13 plus yeah but
sometimes i buy 13 plus you just make
yourself feel better about yourself
inspires me to have 13 socks sometimes
they're too small if they're on the
smaller end they squeeze my feet
they're completely compression it's good
for you you're not wrong so we're going
to start at the beginning of the game
okay beginning of the game you got five
people on the court you got your two
guards where'd they come from oh they
they came from the bench they came from
the school the bench they came from the
locker room the locker room okay how'd
they get to the locker room they were
birthed by their
mother
basketball i need to burn them in this
locker room
everybody get out
i'm making the next nba all-star
don't look at me
don't look
that's the wimpiest way now the real
question the reason people have been
listening at home yeah if someone was
able to jump
from the three-point line and dunk it
would it count as three
okay all right so i'm gonna call this
the fishbach maneuver it's where you
jump and then clamber over all the tall
people
your feet don't touch the ground it's
not against the rules you climb on their
back you jump on like a monkey and then
i use it like mario i'd wall bounce off
of it to the next giant player there
like shadow of the colossal style and i
climb up them and then i slam it in the
hoop
three points baby i'm pretty sure much
like football you can't use another
player to launch
off of their bus
oh that was fish buck maneuver point two
two other guys throw me up into the
basket man there's a lot of things i
haven't explained about basketball about
the personal fouls it's fine you know
this was a this was a primer this was a
getting to know it kind of thing and i
think i know it a lot better now that's
good that was the hope and all we can do
is hope on this podcast